chairman
the boss of the nato jens stoltenberg is wrong
Ukraine is not a democracy
on position parties are prohibited
opposition leaders
his murdered elections are a thing of the past
ukraine is a country
that is led by war criminals
setting up battle positions
in hospitals and schools
who bomb apartment buildings and mall
and who torture and murder prisoners of war
who loot churches and imprison priests
as this parliament has emphasized often enough
Ukrainian is also thoroughly corrupt
celenske and his clique
lock hundreds of millions away
from international aid funds
this political choice for ukraine
has led to greatly increased
Ukrainian organ trafficking child trafficking
arms trade and one hundred thousand migrants
to priceless energy
and messages for our citizens
to the financial abyss of hundreds of thousands of families
in the eu citizens pay the price
and therefore the eu must immediately
stop this war
in ukraine
and use the eu funds for prosperity and peace
for our citizens